fin
bonjour à tous ces mois s'écoulent
affectait qu aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler du rôle d'un procureur un
procureur qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
magistrat du parquet donc de vous au
contraire des juges qui sont de la
magistrature assise
comment devient ton procureur
il est sous la responsabilité du garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
il est donc désigné par arrêté du
gouvernement vous à la tête du parquet
d'un tribunal à quoi sert un procureur
ils représentent le ministère public
donc l'ensemble de la société
comment fait-il cela il mène l'action
publique
il collabore avec la police judiciaire
qu'il en forme des crimes et délits
il dirige enquête lors du jugement de
l'accusé il demande une peine et
vérifient que la loi est respectée il
qu'on donne donc les gens pas seulement
selon le méfait commis
le procureur peut engager des poursuites
opté pour une procédure alternative on
ne pas donner suite à la procédure
quelles sont les missions du procureur
il fait avoir que le procureur a en fait
deux victimes
il intervient donc au pénal où l'on juge
ceux qui ont fraigne la loi mais aussi
au civil où l'on gère les conflits entre
les personnes il s'occupe de
l'administration civile
il intervient dans une foule de domaines
comme l'adoption la tutelle ou la
surveillance de l'état civil
on peut dire que le procureur est un
magistrat important puisqu'il nous
représente nous citoyens face à ceux qui
ont freiné les lois et la bonne marche
de la société
à bientôt pour un nouvel épisode
je